[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihnen allen was in
Nahost passiert wird uns alle betreffen
das galt immer schon das gilt auch jetzt
fünf deutsche Staatsbürger sind nach ZDF
Informationen unter den entführten im
Gazastreifen eine deutsche hat bei dem
terrorüberfall der Hamas auf Israel ihr
Leben verloren insgesamt dürfte es dabei
mittlerweile über 1000 Tote gegeben
haben von einer jungen Frau mit
deutschem Pass heute ein Lebenszeichen
aus einem Krankenhaus in Gaza wohin sie
verschleppt wurde für ihre Familie ein
kleines bisschen Hoffnung einiges an
Frust über die ihrer Meinung nach
enttäuschende Reaktion der deutschen
Behörden und natürlich sehr viel Sorge
meh sind ich als Optimistin dachte mir
das kann do nicht sein dass meine Nichte
chanie tot
ist dieses Mädchen das mehr als jeder
andere für Freiheit Freundschaft und
Liebe steht das kann doch nicht
sein dass sie tot ist das kann nicht
sein das ging mir nicht in den Kopf
ich dachte mir okay sie ist
verletzt sie ist in einer furchtbaren
Situation aber sie wird es
schaffen die Lage für die
Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza ist verheerend
nach heftigen Luftschlägen der Israelis
die Palästinenser dort melden über 800
Tote und die politische Situation
international aktuell dermaßen
angespannt dass man die Dramatik selbst
in dürren diplomatischen Statements
spürt Amerikas Außenminister telefoniert
hektisch die Region ab bittet um
Zurückhaltung und die EU Chefdiplomaten
treffen sich zu einer Krisensitzung ich
rede gleich mit der deutschen
Außenministerin erst l walport über die
aktuelle Lage aus Tel
Aviv Israels Vergeltungsschläge sind
gewaltig mehr als 1000 Tonnen Bomben
haben die Streitkräfte seit dem Hamas
Terrorangriff vom Wochenende auf Ziele
in Gaza abgeworfen auf Stellungen der
Hamas wie der Verteidigung ister beim
Truppenbesuch
betont Gaza wird nicht mehr dasselbe
sein wir werden Hamas komplett
eliminieren aber die Terrorgruppe ist
weiter kampffähig einen ganzen
raketenreigen schossen sie heute wieder
Richtung Israel die meisten wurden vom
israelischen abwehrchirm neutralisiert
einen Schirm den die Palästinenser im
Gazastreifen nicht haben ein Bewohner
schildet wie sein Hochhaus weggebombt
wurde nicht ohne
Vorwarnung der israelische Geheimdienst
rief mich an
und sie fragten mich Zeit in welcher
Etage wohnen Sie im vierten oder im
fünften ich sagte ich wohne im ersten
Stock und er sagte sie haben 7 Minuten
Zeit um den Wohnturm zu
räumen vom Gebäude sind nur noch Trümmer
übrig neben den Todesopfern gibt es
schon jetzt 180000 Menschen hier deren
Wohnungen zerstört sind esoht eine
Versorgungskrise auch die krankenhuser
sind völlig überlastet es fehlen
Medikamente und Strom den Israel
abgestellt
hat wir laufen jetzt hier im Notbetrieb
neben den vielen Verwundeten versuchen
wir mit Mühe chronisch Kranke wie
dialysep Patienten oder auch die
Entbindungsstation weiter zu
versorgen eine Katastrophe die die Hamas
durch ihren kaltblütigen Terror bewusst
herbeigeführt hat mit der die Menschen
in Gaza jetzt weit alleine da stehen
Hamas hat anderes zu tun gleich zwei
Feuergefechte lieferten sich israelische
Soldaten heute mit Terroristen die sich
in grenznahen Dörfern offenbar seit dem
Wochenende verschanzt hatten die Gefahr
so scheint es ist noch nicht
gebannt und während viele Familien im
Land verzweifelt auf Nachrichten über
die Situation der mehr als 100 Geiseln
in der Hand der Hamas warten sind
israelische Sicherheitskräfte immer noch
dabei das Ausmaß dieser Terrorattacke
hier im Dorf quasa zu dokumentieren die
Hamas hatte hier vor allem junge
Familien mit Kindern eiskalt
ermordet sehen Sie selbst das waren
Mütter Väter Babys in 40 Jahren
Militärdienst habe ich so etwas nie
gesehen das ist kein Krieg das ist
Terror und Israel ist fest entschlossen
diesen Terror mit militärischen Mitteln
zu
beantworten wir gehen live nach Tel zu
der Verteidigungsminister wir haben es
gerade kurz gesehen wir haben ihn auch
gerade kurz gesehen sagt wir bewegen uns
auf eine Großoffensive zu Gaza wird
niemals wieder so sein wie es mal war
was heißt das
genau also zunächst einmal gibt es im
ganzen Land die feste Entschlossenheit
es jetzt
mit der Hamas endgültig aufzunehmen also
es gibt eine einen übereinstimmenden
Konsens in breiten Teilen der
Bevölkerung dass es kein Zweck mehr hat
mit dieser Terrorgruppe überhaupt noch
zu verhandeln oder einen irgendwie
gearteten Ausgleich finden zu wollen das
heißt die Streitkräfte die politische
Führung und die meisten Menschen in
Israel sind der Ansicht dass man
tatsächlich militärisch vorgehen muss
dort um diese Gruppe zu eliminieren und
wie viel Opfer man da in der
Zivilbevölkerung und auch möglicherweise
unter den israelischen Geiseln in der
Hand der Hamas in Kauf nimmt das ist
eine offene Frage die im Moment eher
nicht offen diskutiert wird was ist aber
offen in Israel aktuell gibt es eine
Diskussion in der bereits heftige Kritik
auch an Ministerpräsident Benjamin
Netanyahu geübt wird er solle
zurücktreten heißt es da bisweilen und
zwar jetzt und nicht erst nach einem
Krieg erstreckt sich da das Misstrauen
gegen ihn was es ja bei Teilen der
Bevölkerung bereits seit Monaten gibt
wir erinnern uns an die Demonstrationen
auf den Straßen erstreckt sich dieses
Misstrauen jetzt auch auf seinen Umgang
mit der aktuellen
Lage ich glaube ja das kann man so sagen
und überraschend nicht überraschend muss
man sagen ist dass die Kritik du hast es
ja gerade gesagt
aus bekannten Quellen kommt wie
beispielsweise der kritischen links
eingeordneten Tageszeitung hararit aber
neu ist dass auch Blätter die in der
Vergangenheit beispielsweise stramm an
der Seite von Netanyahu standen wie das
Massenblatt Israel ayom die
meistgelesenste Zeitung hier die
meistgelesene Zeitung in Israel und die
eigentlich stramm rechts ist die übt
jetzt deutlich Kritik und macht klar
dass Netanyahu Fehler auf Fehler gemacht
hat er sei so wörtlich er habe sich
selber zu einer Geisel der
rechtsextremen Politiker in seiner
Koalition gemacht er habe den
Verteidigungsminister gefeuert vor
einigen Monaten der musste dann auf
Druck der Straße wieder eingestellt
worden werden er habe die deutlichen
wenhinweise aus den Sicherheitskreisen
den israelischen vernachlässigt also
harscher kann eine Kritik aus dem
eigentlich befreundeten Lager nicht
kommen ist nicht der Moment wo Netanyahu
zurücktreten wird und wo man diese diese
Krise auch dieser militärischen Krise
dieser sicherheitskrise noch eine
politische drauf setzt aber dieser
Moment wird kommen und netanahus Tage
sind wenn nicht gezählt dann doch ja auf
jeden Fall ist der politisch sehr stark
Unterdruck sagt Glück wahport vielen
Dank ja wir erleben eine zesur auch für
einen der viel gesehen und viel erlebt
hat John Kirby Sprecher des Nationalen
Sicherheitsrats im Weißen Haus wird bei
den CNN Kollegen auf die furchtbaren
Bilder aus Israel
angesprochen und muss mit den Tränen
kämpfen sorry very EXC me very difficult
to look at images
jak human cost and these are human
beings family members friends lov ones
Cousins Brothers sisters
ja die bundesaußenministerin ist bei uns
guten Abend Annalena berbor schönen
guten Abend der Sprecher des Nationalen
Sicherheitsrats der USA also übermannt
von den grauenhaften Bildern aus Israel
ist das so dass die Krisen auf der Welt
jetzt auch hartgesottene Politiker
überfordern also ich würde sagen
menschlichkeit ist keine Überforderung
sondern es bringt zum Ausdruck was für
eine zesur diese Brutalität diese
Menschlichkeit die der hamasterror
gezeigt hat für die Menschen in Israel
bedeutet und ich habe das auch in meinem
Telefonat mit dem israelischen
ausminister gespürt wie tief der Schock
die Trauer die Unfassbarkeit sitzt und
in solchen Minuten in solchen
Situationen Menschlichkeit zu zeigen ist
glaube ich die Grundlage für Politik
dann reden wir jetzt darüber was konkret
passieren muss in der Politik die
Europäische Union will die Hilfen nicht
die unmittelbar humanitären aber
generell die Hilfen an die Palästinenser
überprüfen die finanziellen heißt das
Frau berbock sie sind sich nicht ganz
sicher ob sie nicht auch den Terror
unterstützen nein ganz und gar nicht
natürlich machen wir keine
terrorfinanzierung wir leisten im
übrigen auch über die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit das klingt
jetzt alles ein bisschen technisch aber
es gibt die Unterscheidung
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
Stromversorgung Wasserversorgung
Krankenhäuser Schulen das ist
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit das machen
wir fast Überlauf der Welt als
Bundesrepublik als Europäische Union mit
unterschiedlichen Partnern vor Ort z
zusammen aber geben weder für die
Palästinenser noch in anderen Regionen
Budgethilfe das heißt das war auch in
der Vergangenheit nicht der Fall auch in
der Vergangenheit überprüfen wir alles
auch bei der humanitären Hilfe aber weil
das jetzt so eine zesur ist auch der
besondere Wunsch der Israelis überprüfen
wir jetzt bei all unseren Zahlen noch
mal das was wir in der Vergangenheit
auch immer tun überprüfen an wen gehen
die Gelder und für mich für die
Bundesregierung ist wichtig dass wir die
Lebensmittelhilfe die Wasserversorgung
nicht einstellen weil das brauchen jetzt
die Menschen vor Ort ganz ganz dringend
gut dann gibt es noch einen anderen
Punkt der vielleicht auch überprüft
werden sollte und da gibt's geht's um
sehr sehr viel Geld einer der größten
Unterstützer der Hamas ist Qatar
Qatar überwies nach Schätzungen 1,5
Milliarden Euro bislang an die
Terrorgruppe 2012 hat der Emir von Qatar
als erstes Staatsoberhaupt überhaupt das
hamasreime in Gaza besucht ich habe das
damals gesehen drüber berichten müssen
als Korrespondent man konnte da erleben
wie der emier die Hamas regelrecht
gefeiert hat und sie sich gestärkt
fühlte durch sein Geld am Donnerstag
kommt Katars Emir nach Berlin und wird
vom Bundeskanzler empfangen da muss ich
sie jetzt einfach fragen was sind denn
all diese solidaritätsadressen an Israel
wert wenn man dan nach mit dem Geldgeber
des Terrors Mittag ist das heißt ja
nicht dass man sehr deutliche Worte
findet und dass man genau in diesem
Moment und das habe ich getan in den
letzten Tagen das hat der Bundeskanzler
der Bundespräsident getan mit all den
Akteuren in der Region nicht nur
intensiv telefoniert hat sondern
denjenigen Staaten unter anderem Qatar
sehr deutlich gemacht hat dass sie eine
Verantwortung haben diesen brutalsten
Terror jetzt klar die Stirn zu bieten
und das wird auch natürlich das
Hauptthema sein wenn sie hier vor Ort
sind aber Frau ist doch nicht anzunehmen
dass der EM sich daran hält ja wir haben
ja auch große andere Krisen auf der Welt
und da ist es auch zentral dass man in
den Gesprächen deutlich macht wir
akzeptieren keine terrorunterstützung
wir müssen alles dafür tun dass jetzt
für Israel dieser Terrorismus das Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung so genutzt wird
dass diesem Terrorismus ein Ende gemacht
wird und da sind Länder wie Qatar in der
besonderen Verantwortung wir hatten
heute als Europäische Union Gespräche
mit dem Kooperationsrat der Golfstaaten
auch bei den anderen Golfstaaten
deutlich zu machen dass sie ihre Kanäle
und Möglichkeiten nutzen müssen als
allererstes die Geiseln frei kommen
darunter sind ja bekanntermaßen auch
auf dramatische Art und Weise einige
deutsche doppelstaatlerinen und
Doppelstaatler auch das werden wir
intensiv mit Qatar besprechen und in so
einem Moment alles dafür tun dass die
Menschen die auf so bestialische Art und
Weise gefangen genommen worden sind dass
die hoffentlich wieder freikommen und ih
nicht schlimmstes weiter angetan wird
ist ja nicht nur Hamas es gibt den
Palästinenser Präsidenten Mahmud Abbas
im Westjordanland dessen
Sicherheitsbehörden interessanterweise
mit Israel zusammenarbeiten der man
wartet seit gefühlten Ewigkeiten auf
einen eigenen Staat der ist ihm vom
Westen auch von Deutschland versprochen
worden er wird vom Westen alimentiert
auch aus Angst wenn man sagt was kommt
den nach abas kommt dann eventuell auch
im Westjordanland die Hamas an die Macht
ist denn all das wenn Sie sich das mal
zusammenfassen eine Nahostpolitik die zu
irgendwas führt stehen wir nicht auch
vor dem Scherbenhaufen unserer eigenen
Nahostpolitik
das dramatisch ja und es gibt ja nicht
die deutsche in der Ostpolitik sondern
sie ist eingebettet in eine europäische
eng abgestimmt mit den Amerikanern und
das ist ja das dramatische in der
Situation dass wir mit Blick auf die
zwei staatenlösung ja für die
Deutschland immer geworben hat weil es
kann nur politische Lösung geben damit
Palästinenser und Israelis in Frieden
leben können das haben wir Jahrzehnte
nicht erreicht aber jetzt hat's in
jüngerer Vergangenheit eine Annäherung
gegeben zwischen Saudi-Arabien und
Israel z.B und das wollten einige nicht
deswegen haben wir jetzt eine Situation
wo Terroristen unterstützt von
unterschiedlichen Akteuren sicherlich
versuchen genau das zu verhindern und
deswegen ist das gemeinsame agieren
gerade auch mit den Golfstaaten die
diese Annäherung versucht haben jetzt so
wichtig dass wir gemeinsam Deut machen z
statenlösung fr die zwei staatenlösung
will auch Benjamin Netanyahu nicht er
hat ja mehrfach klar gemacht dass er
davon im Grunde nichts hält sein eigener
Finanzminister hat gerade noch mal
Zweifel ob es überhaupt ein
palästinensisches Volk gibt also diese
zwei staatenlösung die hat ja auch ein
Problem bei der israelischen
Regierung bei der aktuellen israelischen
Regierung ist das die Position gewesen
nichtsdestotrotz hat es auch mit dieser
israelischen Regierung eben diese
Gespräche Amerikaner Saudis und Israel
gegeben damit insbesondere hier eine
Annäherung zwischen arabischen Ländern
möglich ist durch diesen Terror wurde
das alles in die Luft gesprengt deswegen
es ist eine zesur deswegen ist oberstes
Gebot in der jetzigen Stunde gerade für
uns als Deutsche als Europäer die
Sicherheit Israels ist deutsche
staatsrison wir stehen an der Seite
Israels mit ihrem legitimen Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung und es muss darüber
hinaus dann alle diplomatischen
Gespräche alle Möglichkeiten ausgelotet
werden weil das perfide dieses Terrors
ist ja das Drehbuch des Terrors ist es
Menschen in der gesamten Region in Angst
und Schrecken äh zu versetzen und dieses
Drehbuch des Terrors das darf keinen
Erfolg haben und das ist Aufgabe von uns
allen äh sie haben es gerade schon kurz
angesprochen Frau bererbock es gibt
offensichtlich mindestens fünf Deutsche
unter den aktuell in Gaza
entführten was können Sie tun für diese
Geiseln oder fühlen Sie sich da komplett
machtlos
aktuell das war in meinem allerersten
Gespräch natürlich mit einem meinen
israelischen Gesprächspartnern mit ein
Thema es gibt ja über 100 zivile Geiseln
darunter auch etliche deutsche Frauen
Kinder mehr kann ich im Detail dazu
jetzt nicht sagen weil es geht um die
Sicherheit dieser Menschen und wir s die
Angehörigen z.B die Flehen gerade zuu
die Bundesregierung an etwas zu tun und
wir hören von Angehörigen israelischer
Geiseln die sich darüber heftigst
beschweren dass die eigene Regierung mit
ihnen bislang gar keinen Kontakt
aufgenommen hat ist das aus deutscher
Sicht anders haben sie Kontakt auch zu
den Angehörigen aktuell die Botschaft
vor Ort das auswtige Amt der Krisenstab
im Auswärtigen Amt steht natürlich mit
den Angehörigen im Kontakt ich habe
Samstag sofort den Krisenstab der
Bundesregierung im Auswärtigen Amt
zusammengerufen damit auch genau diese
Ansprechpartner jetzt vor Ort da sind
wir arbeiten eng mit den Israelis
zusammen aber sie kennen die die Region
ja auch
persönlich ganz gut in dem Moment am
Samstag am Sonntag wo Hamas weiterhin
Gefechte auf israelischen Staatsgebiet
ausgeübt hat die Kontrolle noch nicht
wieder voll hergestellt war war
natürlich klar in diesem Moment war
oberste Aufgabe der israelischen
Regierung erstmal die Terroristen aus
ihrem eigenen Land zurückzudräen und auf
allen Kanälen wird natürlich versucht
diese furchtbare Situation ich glaube
keiner von uns kann sich das vorstellen
was es bedeutet die Bilder zu sehen von
Familienangehörigen die verschleckt
werden auf einen Truck
blutüberströmt diese bialische Art es
ist kaum auszuhalten und nichtdestrotz
ist es unsere auf e mit allen Akteuren
im Gespräch zu sein um zu versuchen dass
diese Menschen endlich wieder freiommen
sagt die bundesaußenministerin Annalena
bbock von den Grünen Frau berbock vielen
Dank danke
ebenso das Gespräch haben wir um 18:30
Uhr aufgezeichnet ich habe die
Außenministerin natürlich auch noch
gefragt warum Deutschland anders als
andere europäische Länder jetzt keine
Militärflugzeuge schickt um deutsche
Staatsbürger aus Israel auszufliegen
nachdem die Lufthansa und andere ja ihre
Flüge komplett gecancelt haben sie
Annalena berbock verteidigte das
Vorgehen mit Hinweis darauf dass es über
100.000 deutsche in Israel gebe und
zunächst etwa für Jugendgruppen eine
priorisierte Lösung gefunden werden
sollte die Regierung sei mit Airlines im
Gespräch sie können auch diesen Teil des
Interviews komplett sehen in unserem
Internetangebot ZDF heute und dann nach
der Aufzeichnung diese aktuelle Meldung
noch kurz vor der Sendung vom
Auswärtigen Amt am Donnerstag und
Freitag soll es jetzt Sonderflüge und
zwar eine ganze Reihe vier pro Tag der
lufthanser geben aus Israel zurück nach
Deutschland weitere Auswirkungen der
Eskalation im Nahen Osten auf die Welt
jetzt bei dir Hanna US-Präsident Biden
hat Israel in einer Rede erneut
uneingeschränkte Unterstützung zugesagt
auch militärisch sollte es nötig sein
konkret kündigte er an sicherzustellen
dass der israelischen Raketenabwehr die
die Munition nicht ausgeht Biden
erklärte zudem dass sich unter den
Geiseln der Hamas auch usstaatsbürger
befenden außerdem berichtete er von
einem Telefonat mit dem israelischen
Premier Netanyahu darin sei es auch
darum gegangen dass Demokratien wie
Israel stärker seien wenn sie auch im
Krieg nach Recht und Gesetz
handelten US-Außenminister blinken hat
angekündigt voraussichtlich am
Donnerstag nach Israel zu reisen dort
wolle er im direkten Gespräch mit der
Regierung her ausfinden wie die USA am
besten helfen könnten der Besuch sei
zudem eine Botschaft der Solidarität und
Unterstützung hieß es aus dem US
Außenministerium der UN Hochkommissar
für Menschenrechte Türk hat die
komplette Abriegelung des Gazastreifens
durch Israel als völkerrechtswidrig
bezeichnet Menschen das vorzuenthalten
was sie zum Überleben brauchten sei
unter dem humanitären Völkerrecht
verboten sagte er in Genf die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation forderte
einen humanitären Korridor zur
Versorgung der Zivilbevölkerung im
Gazastreifen
einzurichten die Bundesregierung hat
weitere umfangreiche Militärhilfen für
die Ukraine angekündigt darunter ein
luftverteidigungspaket im Wert von rund
einer Milliarde Euro neben einem zweiten
Patriot System enthält es zudem weitere
irist Systeme mit Lenkflugkörpern zudem
sollen unter anderem Kampfpanzer und
Munition geliefert werden laut
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius soll
dies die Einsatzbereitschaft der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte im Winter
weiter
erhöhen die am Sonntag festgestellten
Schäden an der Gaspipeline die Estland
und Finnland durch die Ostsee verbindet
sind laut finnischer Regierung
wahrscheinlich auf Fremdeinwirkung
zurückzuführen Ermittlungen dazu stünden
aber erst am Anfang das seismologische
Institut Norwegens erklärte es habe eine
mutmaßliche Explosion vor der finnischen
Küste registriert auch eine entlang der
Baltic Connector verlaufende
Datenleitung ist beschädigt die 2019 in
Betrieb genommene Pipeline könnte
monatelang ausfallen die Gasversorgung
Finland soll aber nicht gefährdet sein
bei ratzien in der sogenannten
reichsbürgerszene sind in mehreren
Bundesländern Verdächtige festgenommen
worden die Durchsuchungen standen laut
den Ermittlungsbehörden in Zusammenhang
mit der mutmaßlichen Terrorgruppe
vereinte Patrioten diese soll einen
politischen Umsturz in Deutschland und
eine Entführung von
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
geplant haben fünf mutmaßliche
Mitglieder der Gruppierung stehen
deshalb bereits seit Mai vor
Gericht die Bilder lassen wirklich
niemanden kalt junge Partybesucher in
Israel die vor gnadenlosen
Terrorkommandos aus Gaza um ihr Leben
rennen verängstigte Menschen in der Hand
eines mörderischen Regimes und dann auch
in Gaza palästinensische Kinder schwer
verletzt und blutend in zerbombten
Straßen nach Luftangriffen der
Israelis mit dem Massaker der Hamas hat
sich der narostkonflikt wieder neu in
die Schlagzeilen gebrannt und in die
Gemüter die Reaktionen darauf sind
allerdings alles andere als neu es gibt
wieder schwererträglichen Jubel auf
deutschen Straßen über Terrortaten es
gibt solidaritätsadressen an Israel und
es gibt erbitterte Diskussionen
Deutschland ist gezwungen sich damit zu
beschäftigen Christiane Hoffmann und
Kamran
safjaran
Solidarität mit Palästina fordern sie
Sympathisanten auf einer proalästiner
Demonstration gestern in Duisburg
unterstützt auch von der
pramasorganisation samidun wie steht man
hier zum Hamas Terror gegen Israel
machen auch vieles falsch aber im
Betracht dessen was sie machen um
Palästina zu befreien da stehe ich
hinter ihnen dass sie Frauen Kinder weiß
ich nicht was noch alles töten da bin
ich dagegen hundertprozentig ich
distenziere mich mit Gewalt
zur nur Gewalt aber dass man nur dies
Gewalt jetzt sieht und Gewalt Israel
seit 70 Jahren auf die
Palästinenser sieht und auf einmal wenn
die Israelis einmal geschüttelt sind
dann ist die Hölle los auf der Welt ganz
anders sehen das liberale Muslime heute
in Berlin interreligiöses Gebet für
Frieden inost die
imamines verurteil den Terrorangriff der
Hammers
uneingeschränkt ich würde sagen ich zu
den Mens Dieter den noch sehr gelehmt
und meine volle Solidarität täglich nur
wie ich nur kann mit Israel aussprechen
kann in einem offenen Brief kritisieren
Aesch Wissenschaftler und Politiker das
Schweigen der Islamverbände zu den
jubelbildern der hamasanhänger nennen es
beschämend im Fokus der Zentralrat der
Muslime er verurteilt die Angriffe der
Hamas zwar doch weiter heißt es zutiefst
verstörend ist dass Siedler flankiert
durch die israelische Armee seit zwei
Jahren palästinensische Dörfer und die
alxa Moschee angreifen ohne dass die
internationale Gemeinschaft eingreift
dieses berhte Schweigen tut weh weil wir
von den Verbänden erwarten dass sie sich
zur Demokratie zu unserer Verfassung und
den Menschenrechten bekennen sie müssen
jetzt erklären dass sie zur Demokratie
stehen und gegen die Gewalt von
Terroristen gegenüber dem ZDF stellt der
Vorsitzende des Zentralrats der Muslime
jetzt klar für mich Hamas eine
extremistische
Terrororganisation die Mittel anwendet
die ich als Gläubiger
nicht anwenden kann und D ablehne wir
müssen klar benennen dass die dass die
Situation sich in den letzten Jahren
nicht nur verschlechtert hat
insbesondere auch für die Palästinenser
und wenn wir ernsthaft interessiert sind
an einer friedlichen Lösung dann müssen
die Konfliktparteien miteinander
sprechen radikale Palästinenser und
hamasanhänger aber feiern die Angriffe
auf Israel wie hier am letzten Samstag
in Berlin laut Verfassungsschutz gilt
Deutschland als Rückzugsraum für
hamasanhänger 450 Sympathisanten gibt es
Hamas Propaganda ist seit Z Jahren in
Deutschland verboten also ist keine
große Gruppe sie ist auch nicht
aufgefallen bisher durch militante
Aktion aber da weiß man nie das haben
wir in anderen Situationen auch erlebt
wenn die Konflikte aus anderen Regionen
der Welt hier überschwappen ist alles
denkbar die Behörden haben heute zwei
für Mittwoch in Berlin geplante
Solidarität Kundgebungen für
Palästinenser verboten der
Nahostkonflikt der hamasterror er
polarisiert Muslime in
Deutschland und deshalb im heute journal
Update später noch ein Gespräch zum
Thema mit einem islamexerten erfdert
eine Zeitenwende in der
Religionspolitik jetzt aber erstmal hier
bei uns noch mal du Hanna ja und zwar
mit dem Blick auf die Finanzmärkte die
ja normalerweise durchaus empfindlich
auf geopolitische Konflikte reagieren
doch trotz der Eskalation im Nahen Osten
zeigt sich der deutsche leidindex heute
robust Valerie Haller er hat sogar
zugelegt wie ist das zu erklären damit
dass Anleger die geopolitischen Risiken
also die Gefahr dass der Konflikt sich
über die Region hinaus ausweitet als
gering einschätzen würde der Iran mit
hineingezogen könnte es zu
Einschränkungen bei Öllieferung und bei
der Förderung kommen und das hätte dann
doch massive Folgen für die
Weltwirtschaft eine Gefahr die anlege
aktuell nicht zu sehen scheinen im d gab
es heute so gut wie keine Verlierer er
beendet den Tag mit fast 2% im Plus
Rückenwind kam von Kursgewinnen under
der Wall Street auch der leicht
gefallene Ölpreis und die Aussicht auf
eine Zinspause in den USA haben den
deutschen Markt gestürzt viel mehr als
eine Momentaufnahme ist all das
allerdings nicht ja und dann gab es
heute auch noch einen Dämpfer vom
Internationalen Währungsfond genau der
IWF hat seine Konjunkturprognose für
Deutschland noch mal nach unten
geschraubt demnach wird sie
voraussichtlich diese dieses Jahr um
0,5% schrumpfen damit wäre Deutschland
klassenletzter als einzige große
Volkswirtschaft mit einem Minus beim
Wachstum für die Weltwirtschaft
insgesamt sind die EWF Ökonomen zwar
etwas optimistischer meinen aber sie
humpelt vor sich hin sie sprintet nicht
vielen Dank Valerie für diese
Einordnung wegen steigender Kosten
erhöht die Deutsche Bahn einen Teil
ihrer Fahrpreise im Fernverkehr zum
Fahrplanwechsel ab dem 10 Dezember
Kosten Flex Tickets 4,9% mehr und der
Preis für die bahncart 25 steigt um 3 €
auf jährlich
62,90 € Spar und suersparpreise werden
nicht erhöht dort entfällt aber das City
Ticket die kostenfreie Mitnutzung des
Nahverkehrs am Start und
Zielort im nächsten Jahr findet die
Fußballeuropameisterschaft ja
bekanntlich in Deutschland statt und
seit heute steht fest wer die Gastgeber
in den darauffolgenden Jahren sein
werden die Fußball EM 2028 wird in
Großbritannien und Irland ausgetragen
und auch die Gastgeber für das Jahr
2022 wurden von der UEFA bekannt gegeben
auch hier sind es zwei Austragungsorte
nämlich Italien und die
Türkei nach einem fast 5 Monate langen
Streik haben in Hollywood die
Drehbuchautoren einem neu ausgehandelten
Vertrag mit den Studios und
streaminganbietern zugestimmt die
autorengewerkschaft erklärte 99% ihrer
Mitglieder hätten sich für das neue
Angebot ausgesprochen es en hält unter
anderem Lohnerhöhungen und ist bis Mai
2026 gültig anders sieht es dagegen bei
den Schauspielern in Hollywood aus hier
gehen die Streiks und Verhandlungen
weiter ja das war neues aus der
Traumfabrik an einem nicht besonders
einfachen nachrichtentag danke dass Sie
mit uns dabei waren und gegen 0:20 Uhr
begrüßt Sie hier Christopher W mit
unserem heute journal Update im Namen
aller hier im Studio Regie Redaktion
Produktion einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend spätestens am
Wochenende ändert sich das Wetter
aktuell aber haben wir es noch mit Hochs
zu tun nämlich mit dem Hoch Ulrike und
dem hoch
und mit Tiefs wie Ralf und Kiron die
doch Regenwolken vor allen Dingen in den
Norden Deutschlands bringen aber vor
allen Dingen trennen diese Wolken sehr
tiefe Temperaturen über dem Norden
Europas mit nur so 5 bis 10° zum Teil
kannst du auch schon kräftig schneien
von noch mal sehr spätsommerlicher Wärme
im Südwesten mit 25 bis 35°. auch unsere
Nachttemperaturen aktuell sind sehr mild
16° sind es heute Nacht auf nordernei 7°
auf der Schwäbischen al und dazu ist der
Himmel in Süddeutschland meist klar da
kann sich lokal an der Donau oder auch
am Boden ser etwas Nebel bilden in
Norddeutschland gibt's mehr Wolken und
mehr Wind und daher keinen Nebel der Tag
morgen beginnt freundlich mit viel
Sonnenschein allerdings werden die
Wolken von Norden schon dichter und
spätestens ab den frühen
Nachmittagsstunden regnet es dann in
Niedersachsen in scheswig-holstein
später dann auch in Mecklenburg
Vorpommern bei einem starken bis
stürmischen Wind aus westsüdwestlichen
Richtungen direkt an der See liegen
morgen so die Temperaturen bei 17 bis
20° sonst werden 21 bis 28° erreicht der
Regen von morgen liegt dann am
Donnerstag in der Mitte Deutschlands und
verhartt dort am Freitag wird's dann
stürmisch und dann deutlich kälter und
das sehen Sie hier am Trend für München
sehr deutlich am Freitag liegen dort die
Werte noch über 25 am Sonntag unter 15°
guten Abend